i ended up getting pregnant
when i was 13
with my son
and
i was still in foster care at the time
and i ended up
it was as a whole fiasco my
my boyfriend at the time his my son's
dad he ended up
robbing a store and doing all this [ __ ]
because he was he thought he was in high
school had a kid on the way i guess he
was going crazy he didn't know
and this was a nice little country boy
when i met him
and
i guess after a while he wasn't and his
family i think kind of blamed me or
something because i was this kind of
city girl that was
you know
too fast
too fast for him for their nice little
country boy
and um
i ended up moving to jackson michigan
when i had my son
his dad got out of uh he ended up
getting cough rob in the store and he
got out of juvie at the time because he
was only
17 maybe when he did it
and
he got out like a month before i had my
son and so i had my son i'm still in my
same foster home and but my foster mom
she ended up things were okay there at
first
things were they they were okay
and then
i think she got really angry at me for
being pregnant uh
when i was 13. she couldn't have kids of
her own
and uh
she started
not starving me but really restricting
my food like you know you can only have
one egg and one hash brown for breakfast
like that's it
you know
there's one one sandwich with only so
many pieces of meat for lunch like
that's all you get and i'm like i'm
pregnant right now i'm hungry
like
it was it was messed up so and um i
didn't get out of there until about a
month after i had my son
oh because she also used me as like she
wanted me to do all the housework all
the cleaning and
cooking and and and like i just had a
baby
like you really want me in here you know
cooking and washing dishes and doing
mopping and all this i can't
so my my foster mom uh
i guess she went she was just
that's that's what i think happened i
think she was mad at me for having kids
when she couldn't
and so now
me and my boyfriend and we got a kid and
now we're on our own and we're like
we're like adults now yeah sure [ __ ] it
i you know i've been making all my own
decisions my entire life like
this is not a big big deal it's really
not
and
at the time my son he's like
he's small
and i know i'm supposed to hold him
it's crazy like i read this book called
what to expect the first year
it's it's what you read like when you're
gonna have a kid to know like what's
going on with them the first year of
their life so you can recognize like any
kind of
illnesses or just anything you know and
and they're developmental milestones so
you can keep track of it and you know
what's going on with your kids so i read
that book and that was like the only
guidance i had to being a parent like i
did i didn't know anything else besides
what was in this book
but i knew like you know i'm supposed to
hold him and love him
and so i
i do that and i'm breastfeeding him and
i'm just i'm trying to be the best
mother possible at
at 14
15 and
but i have all this anger and trauma
and sometimes
i had this problem with like
being touched like
affectionately like
no one had ever really touched me
affectionately like
in a safe way
you know my mom she really didn't hug me
or you know kiss me on the forehead pat
me on the back what the [ __ ] you do with
a kid my mom didn't do that
and no one did that when i was in foster
care either
but i know i'm supposed to hug my son
and hold him and love him so that's what
i do
but sometimes it's too hard i can't
i couldn't stand
for him to touch me my skin would crawl
and i didn't
i didn't want that to happen so i kept
holding him
and at the same time my boyfriend at the
time gosh we had sex all the time but i
couldn't hold his hand
i couldn't i couldn't be affectionate
with him i couldn't
i couldn't be nice he's like i never met
somebody that wants to have sex so much
but doesn't want
any kind of affection
and when i was like 14 and 15
i didn't know why i was like that
i didn't know what was wrong with me
but i couldn't
i couldn't stop being angry i had all
this hate
from my father and it was weighing me
down all the time it was so heavy
and
after some time maybe when i was around
15 i realized that
it was too heavy for me to carry around
i had to let it go like he was still
he was still controlling me i hadn't
seen this man
you know
since i was 10 years old and somehow he
was still running my thoughts every
single day
i'm like how do you let somebody do that
to you when you haven't even they're
controlling you and you haven't even
seen him so i'm like i gotta stop
i have to stop this
so i just
i guess it had to do with the control
um i always wanted to be in control of
everything
around me you know i wanted to call the
shots and i felt like my dad was calling
the shots when he was always in my head
and so that made me drop it really quick
i'm like yeah no he's not going to
control me anymore
so i let go
of that part you know of the trauma i
stopped hating him
just because it was so damn heavy
and uh
when my son was around four
um
that was when i started to spank him
and i thought
that because i wasn't beating him like
breaking his bones i wasn't sexually
abusing him
i'm like yeah spanking's okay you can
spank a kid when they need to get
spanked
and so like
once in a while
he would get you know the smack on his
butt for something
and then by the time he was like
six
maybe
because the first time i spanked him he
was four and then by the time he was
like six
there was a moment
where
i kind of lost control
he got
he got in trouble at school
and he came home
and i'm questioning him like why did you
do this or why did you do that
and i slap his face because he's not
answering me and this is the first time
i
i put my hands on his face or you know
didn't just try to
give him what i thought at the time was
just like you know a little spanking
because i i felt like you know i don't
know how to discipline kids
but this doesn't seem that bad and plus
i'm not a man
i would not allow
his father to ever touch him because i
was like no you're too strong your hands
are too big
and no
like if if he's gonna be punished i'll
spank
him and so that's how i was and then
this one incident
i don't know what happened
i started slapping him
and slapping his face
and asking him why he did something and
i was slapping him over and over and his
face was getting redder and redder
and he's like
he's like mom you're gonna kill me
and i was like oh my god
okay
all right all right okay
i need to get a hold of myself like
right now
right [ __ ] now and i looked at his
little face and how red it was
and how sad he looked
and i was like oh my god i'm like my dad
i can't do this i have to stop
i have to figure this [ __ ] out i gotta
figure it out because i cannot be like
him
i can't lose control i'm not gonna be
angry
and i'm not gonna hurt my kids
so after that
you know i never hit him in his face
again
and if he got a spanking it was like
once a year like it had to be something
like
you know i was you know just something
where i was like okay maybe that's uh
maybe you need a spanking
and at that time i still thought it was
okay
like i'm doing okay
and so i start um
our relationship
with my relationship with his father was
pretty bad
i ended up having
a daughter with him
when i was 19.
and uh
there was always a
a play for power in our relationship the
the dynamics uh
he figured out
really quickly that he couldn't uh
well he wasn't gonna hit me
when we were kids we got into like a
couple fistfights
but we were kids
when that
happened
and there was like three incidents where
there was physical violence between
me and my son's father
and then it didn't happen anymore
so he had to figure out other ways to
try to control me
because i wasn't gonna
ever cower
in front of any physical violence so
that was not gonna work
and so he would use my kids
and
money
to control me
and uh
if my kids needed anything
you know i would have to do something
for him
uh
some kind of
some kind of sexual uh
whatever he could think of
i had to do it for him if if i wanted
money because the kids needed coats or
clothes or we needed food in the house
i had to do something for him first
and uh
when
i was maybe
i was 22 almost 23. my daughter was
three and my son was eight
and i started to realize that um
i need to be a better mother
and i'm never gonna be a better mother
if i'm with
their father
i'm never gonna heal myself i'm never
gonna be happy
and i need to get my [ __ ] together
but because these kids mean everything
to me they're
my only family
i don't have anybody else there's no one
else besides them and so i gotta get it
together from for them
and um
when i left him uh
my son was eight
he didn't
he didn't know anything about my son
like he didn't know
the names of his teachers his friends he
didn't know his favorite color like
my son had this nickname a baby name
that he didn't want to be called anymore
he just wanted to be called his birth
name
and his his dad
would always call him that and i would
see the hurt on my son's face anytime
his dad called him that he'd say don't
call me that call me this
and it's just kind of like
his dad didn't know anything about him
or
and it hurt me
it hurt me that his dad was so damn
absent
in his life
and i made a decision i was like
is my
i felt like having no father
was better than one that was
there but just absent as [ __ ] you know
so i made that decision and my daughter
at the time she was three and she was a
daddy's little girl
but she was three so i didn't felt like
she had a stay in the matter
it was more about how i was feeling how
my son was feeling
and we're getting out of here
so
when i left him
i
had this
99
red dodge durango and i packed it up
full of
their clothes and all their toys
and i was i was going to school full
time at the time i was a pre-med student
i was going to be a doctor
because
i said after all this time i had never
let
my schoolwork slip and i was you know
avid reader
i just kind of always found a way to i
guess lose myself academically so i
didn't have to pay attention anything
else about myself or in my life or
you know the depression
um
suicidal
tendencies
i remember swallowing a bottle of pills
at one of my foster homes
but that was a long time ago i felt like
i had i had come
a long way since then but i was starting
to feel like that again so i was like we
gotta go so i packed up the packed up
the truck packed up my kids
and
well i don't have any family i don't
have anybody so where am i going to go
what am i going to do i'm this foster
kid that slipped through the cracks
so who do you call
i called uh
i don't i didn't at that time i didn't
know where my mom was she was off in the
wind she was moving around
you know from state to state florida to
new york like what the [ __ ] is my mom
doing in new york city like she's
from the country
just
she she was just everywhere she was all
over the place
my mom wasn't stable
and i didn't really talk to her there
was
we were still trying to
mend our relationship
i wasn't as angry
at her
anymore
i had learned a lot of her story
and realized what had happened to her
and so i came to understand that you
know she couldn't uh
she couldn't have been there for me
nobody was ever there for her
so
and no one taught her how to be there
like
things need to be taught you have to
pass things down and if you you can't
just expect somebody to know somebody to
know something because they're out here
living in the world and they're just
supposed to pick it up
you know
you have to learn things you have to be
taught we're all on these different
paths and you know some people they have
a
you know uh
they have a nice walk on a sidewalk and
then maybe a puddle they gotta jump over
and a hill
and then they're they're there to the
destination and then some people they
have nothing but
mountains with oceans in between on
their path
and then they finally get to where
you're at
and you wonder where the [ __ ] they've
been
but you didn't see everything they had
to go through just to be as
average as you
to be as normal as you
and it's not only that it's not just the
path it's
you know we're all
we all have these tools that we start
out with or that we're given or that we
acquire
along the way and
i viewed my mother as weak
because i felt like she didn't have the
same
because she didn't stand up
but i had to learn
what my mom had been through i had to
learn her path
and i had to learn
the tools
that she was given
to understand
you know
why i went through what i went through
i had to understand her life
and in part you know i had to understand
my fathers as well
and
at that point when i was deciding that i
need to do better and i need to leave
this man i need to leave my husband i
need to leave the father of my kids
my mom was on the part of her path
where
she still didn't know what was going on
with her
like she didn't even understand her own
trauma
so i left him i didn't have anybody to
call so i called my middle sister
and uh
she lived in ann arbor at the time
she just graduated from u of m and
um she had came to live with me and my
husband a couple times
and so i felt like it was and we had
gotten close during those times so i
felt like it was okay for me to reach
out and ask her
i was like hey i'm you know i'm leaving
him can me and the kids come stay with
you
while we get in our get on our feet
and uh she said no and she suggested
that i call a homeless shelter
and so i said okay
that's what i'll do
i'll call the homeless shelter
and uh
so i'm in college
i think i'm taking like 18 credits i'm
going full time
you know i want to be a doctor that's
what i want to do i was always that kid
that was so smart and everybody's like
you know they're going to be a doctor or
they're going to be a lawyer you know i
mean that's what you tell the smartest
kid
and so that's what i thought i was going
to do
and so i have my kids and uh
we're at this homeless shelter and i
i'm trying to do it like i'm in school
i'm still going full time i'm taking my
kids to school and picking them up after
i get out of school and
you know and then i'm trying to get us
out of this shelter so i'm working this
third shift job at 7-eleven
in like
i realized pretty quickly that uh
that's not going to get us out of the
homeless shelter
like you need support you need family
and this was a shelter where they
actually only allow you to stay a month
but i guess they took pity on me because
they knew i'd like
had no one like i have no support system
what do you want me to do
like we're gonna be here or we're gonna
be sleeping in our car
and um
so when i was with my husband all those
years i had been completely uh
monogamous with him there was a lot of
infidelity on his side but
you know i was when i was with him even
after everything he did i was still so
in love with him i actually had to force
myself to fall out of love with him the
last year that we were together
because i had left him once before when
i was
17 18 but i ended up going back to him
and that's when i got pregnant with my
daughter and so the last time when i
left i wanted to make sure i didn't go
back
so i just spent like the last year just
like pushing him out of my heart like
anytime he did anything that was gonna
make me happy or smile or anything i
would think of something bad he did to
me
and so i just you know just kept pushing
him away and pushing him away and then
when i finally left him i was like yeah
i'm not going back
so i made sure i did that before i left
and uh
it had been about
four months
after i left him since i hadn't had sex
with anybody else and i always had a
high sex drive
extremely high and uh
you know my
so i started sleeping around while i'm
like in school
homeless
got my kids
and i'm working in this full-time third
shift 7-eleven job
and i don't just walk up to anybody be
like you want to [ __ ]
like i just no finesse nothing like i
don't want your phone number i don't
give a [ __ ] about who you are your name
anything would you like to have sex with
me yeah can i get your number no right
now
like do you want to go right now
and i never got turned down
of course i mean
and so
that was like my
that lasted for maybe like
i don't know a couple months for sure
and uh
then
i was at school one day
and i'm still in the homeless shelter at
this point and like we're at this point
we're there like six months and i'm like
okay we're i'm i feel like we're about
to overstay our welcome and they're
going to ask us to leave
and i still
don't know what i'm going to do
i'm going to school and i have
a job and
yeah this 7-eleven money is not going to
get us anywhere
and i have no one to call i have no one
to ask for help i remember
a couple weeks after i had left
my kid's father
i was on the side of the road like the
car had ran out of gas and i'm just like
just [ __ ] out of luck like what are you
gonna do you're homeless you have kids
you have no money you have nobody to ask
calling around like nobody has i called
my sister because she lives in the same
town
she because
i knew i wanted to be in ann arbor
like i had to be in ann arbor because
all the homes and different cities i
moved around to when i was in foster
care i saw the education systems
and i was like
they're they're different they're
different everywhere you go depending on
you know the
a lot of it has to do with money and
basically i just wanted my kids to be in
ann arbor and get get an ann arbor
education
that's what i wanted and so i was like
i'm staying in ann arbor i don't care if
i could drive somewhere else and it
might be easier to get on my feet
that's not what's happening
i have these kids and we are here in ann
arbor because i want them to go to ann
arbor public schools i want them to
have a good start because i knew that
education was important
and uh
good education is important um
i was a
anyways it was just sucked i was poor i
was homeless i had two kids
and i didn't have any help i had no
support so one day i was at school
oh and i was wild i would i would even
meet people at school i would like come
out to the parking lot with me real
quick you want to [ __ ]
i didn't i didn't know what was going on
so i met this guy one day um at school
uh
in college
i had seen him in the library
i was like damn he looks fine as hell
let me go talk to him
and so he gets up to leave and i'm like
on this uh the second floor it looks
down into the library it's still part of
the library and um
i see him walking leaving out and he's
going towards the stairwell so i'm like
dashing to the store stairwell
and i'm like hey wait a minute what's
your name
and uh so he tells me his name and i'm
like
i think i said
do you want to have sex or you want to
[ __ ] i said something like that and he
was the first one like some guys were
kind of taken aback by it they're like
whoa
like they think i'm playing a joke on
them
and i'm like no [ __ ]
i don't know what's wrong with me i'm
just really horny
so
um
i asked him that and like we're talking
in the stairwell and he's trying to he's
asking me some questions about myself
and he was like
i told him i was homeless because he
wanted to know and like all throughout
my life any anytime anybody ever asked
me a question i was always really
straight up with them like i told them
what it was like you're gonna be in my
life or you're not but this is what it
is if you're gonna be here
and uh
he was like well
if that's what's going on with you
and you're out here giving it away for
free
you might as well get paid for it
i'm like well [ __ ] i never heard a
better idea in my life like i'm [ __ ]
homeless
and i got two kids let's go sell some
[ __ ] then like that's what i'm thinking
i'm like
you know at first
yeah i'm gonna say i was 100
on board like right away
i was he convinced me there in the
stairwell
i'd never even heard about prostitution
really like i didn't know anything about
it besides
i had a little brush with it
while i was in that shelter
one of the jobs i ended up getting was
at a bar
and i was only there for three days you
don't want to see me in a bar i don't
know how to work in a bar it was a hot
mess okay
like i'd never been around
alcohol really
and uh
too much except when i was a kid i was
drinking when i was a kid from like
oh
nine to thirteen but after that i really
didn't touch alcohol anymore so
this was my like first time being around
alcohol again and my my boss had told me
yeah if someone wants to buy you a shot
have them buy you the most expensive
shot
and i was like okay
and so
my first couple nights like three nights
people are buying me shots like all
night long and i'm getting drunker and
drunker and i start dropping my tabs
everywhere
and my boss is like pissed he's like
what's going on i remember one time he
came to talk to me and i just dropped
all them and they were all disordered
right in front of him and i told him you
wanted me to take these shots like well
you expect he was like you're supposed
to tell the bartender is for you and
they're supposed to fill it up with
water
i'm like well [ __ ] i didn't know that
how am i supposed to know that i never
worked at a bar before i didn't know i
was supposed to take shots of water like
you got to tell me these things
the bar owner i guess had had his eye on
me
and
i stopped coming in after that because i
was like you know what this is not for
me this is not the environment i need to
be in
i was like i'm not mentally um
i've always been
spontaneous
really spontaneous and like have this i
don't give a [ __ ] attitude but i've
tried to stay away from things that
would encourage that attitude in me
so i'm like this is not the environment
for me to be in i'm trying to be in
school i have these kids
you know you know the story and so
my boss calls me like a couple days and
he's like the owner the owner of the bar
calls me a couple days and he's like why
why haven't you been in for your shift
nah i told him i was like yeah i don't
think it's going to work out and he's
like aren't you homeless because that
was how i got the job i'm like i'm
homeless give me a job
and um
uh
so we end up talking on the phone and he
he says he can help me out with some
money and so i ended up meeting him
at a hotel by the detroit metro airport
and
him and his friend i end up meeting his
friend this is the worst
they gave me a hundred dollars
for two of them and i was like i didn't
know i had never prostituted before like
how much does [ __ ] cost i don't know
like don't ask me i never sold it
so they gave me a hundred dollars but
when they gave me 100 and there there
had been two of them i'm like i'm pissed
because i don't know how much [ __ ]
costs but i know it costs more than 100
it's like this and [ __ ]
but you know they both had their penises
were like this so it wasn't that big of
a deal you know had the i would have
been pissed if they you know had really
beat me up for it but i mean both of
them came in like 20 seconds some video
wasn't that that bad but i was still
pissed i was like this thing right so i
had that little brush with prostitution
that happened to me
and um
i was like okay i don't know what i'm
doing and yeah i didn't know what to do
so when i met i met my pimp
and that stairwell and he told me
and like he sounded like he knew what to
do
so i'm like yeah let's do this like i
want i want to get out of this shelter i
want to i want to get my kids you know
in an apartment i want us to have our
own stuff
and so um
people might wonder like you know how
does it happen
i remember uh
so that weekend he had me
go with him to this uh house party
and uh
no i met him at a hotel first before the
house party
and we had sex
and he was like
wow you really set the bar high
and then
we went to this house party and he had
me at the end of the party he had me uh
he said
pick out four guys that you liked around
here
at the party
and so
i walk around the ground and like
pick out four guys
and we ended up going back to one of
their places
and uh
they're all sitting around taking shots
and drinking and i already know that's
not for me
because i said it before i'm like
yeah not for me out of control and so um
oh out of control because i ended up
[ __ ] a regular in the bathroom at
that bar
so this
i'm only there three days
and i don't know how to waitress i don't
know how to do anything i know how to
[ __ ]
[ __ ] regular and
like on my shift during my shift
and then i had a i had another
this was a small bar too so if you're
[ __ ] the regulars it gets really
small really quick
you know and so
i [ __ ] another regular like after my
shift on that same day
and then like the next day that other
regular i had [ __ ] in the bathroom is
is like grabbing at me and then there's
this other guy i've been talking to like
around the corner i'm trying to make
sure this he doesn't see this other guy
grabbing him
it was a hot mess so anyways i knew i
knew to say no to alcohol i'm like no
absolutely not and uh so these guys are
sitting around taking shots they ask me
if i want to drink i don't know what's
going to happen really
i guess i got a clue
maybe
but i don't know so and they're like
asking me if i want to drink it i'm like
no absolutely not
and uh
went going to the bedroom and
so i i started having sex with these
guys like
one after the other and then
at the end it's it's my pimp and one
other guy and then at the end it's just
my pimp and it's going on for
a couple hours
and i guess that's how you get like i
guess that's how he broke me in
you know how you get broken in and ready
for the streets
and because that was a friday night
and then by the saturday night um
we're downtown detroit
and he's taking me to the mgm
and he had me dress up all cute you know
put on these
heels i'd never worn heels before i
don't know what the hell i'm doing in
heels
and i'm trying to be beautiful in this
casino and attract men and talk to men
and uh find these clients
and at the same time you know
i'm like i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
doing with my life
i'm in school
i'm gonna be a doctor
i have kids i'm trying to be a better
mother
at this point
my son is eight my daughter's three i've
never laid a hand on my daughter
and my son
i try really hard not to spank him so
like i said it only happens like
once a year
or if i can think back to it maybe twice
a year so i'm getting a hold on my anger
as well
but there's something still inside of me
i guess i turned it inward
and i felt
like i became even more
self-destructive i had been
self-destructive my entire life
with all the anger and all the
situations i got myself into
but i felt like this was even more
self-destructive but at the same time i
didn't have another answer about what i
was supposed to do
to get us out of this homeless shelter
i didn't have any family i didn't have
anybody to call like what do you what do
you do
and so um
[Music]
i start working at
the mgm in
in greek town
and uh motor city
here in detroit
and i'm walking around for like 12 hours
a night
in five inch heels
and little dresses
and i'm
picking up these strangers
going up to the rooms with them or there
is this
down the street from motor city there is
this uh
a motel where you can rent a room for
i think it's an hour or two hours for
thirty dollars i could take a trick
there for thirty dollars
and like i mean you know you can take
people in another all night
so i do that um
and i would go home in the morning
because now this is my new third shift
job
[ __ ] 7-eleven
you know
and then um after maybe like two or
three weeks i had us out of there
we had an apartment and we had we you
know had a couch and have a tv but you
know we had things now we have our own
stuff
and nobody can take it from me
and
so i'm working third shift all the time
third shift prostitute
and um
i'm still trying to treat it like a like
a job like i gotta get home on time i
gotta i gotta take my kids to school i
gotta go to school myself
and uh
after
after school i get out of school i have
to pick up my kids from school and then
i'm a pre-med student so i have lots and
lots of homework
like a lot
um and it's like you got to study you
got to do homework you got to take care
of the kids you know do the laundry run
errands
and after a while i couldn't after a
couple years i think it was maybe
two
two years
of that i couldn't do it anymore
like i was
i was exhausted i was so tired
and sometimes bad stuff would happen to
me
while i was
working downtown in detroit
uh
you know some people when they pay
to have sex with you they think um
that they own you
and they try to treat you like that
but i've never been uh
like i said after my father nobody's
gonna hurt me and get away with it
so
you know i remember i
i had this one client he kept biting me
and biting my face and he was doing it
like a joke like joking around
and he was on top of me and i'm like you
got to stop
stop biting my face
and he did it one more time and he did
it really hard
i ended up leaving a mark on my cheek
but you know i just went nuts i started
hitting him i end up breaking his nose i
bit a hole in his face it's not funny
but
that's what happened
and
um
there's just a lot of stuff
like that where somebody would try to do
something to me
but i was just
i just couldn't let happen like i got to
get home to my kids
this is what i have to do
and so
i mean if you want to learn how to be a
hoe
you you're going to learn really fast in
detroit
you really are
um
my pimp would take me around to bars i
would just you know walk in a bars try
to pick up clients
and when you do that kind of work it's
uh
you know you got to have confidence you
got to be able to talk to somebody and
i guess it helps to be
beautiful and uh
i was lonely and i was alone and me and
my pimp uh besides that first time
you know at the hotel and then at
his friend's house we didn't have sex he
uh he brought me into his family
he had me meet his mom you know
cooked dinner with her one time i dyed
her hair you know i met a sister
he brought me into his family and
treated me like family and that's how he
kept me
under his thumb that's how he kept me
handing my money over to him
because he did things for me that you
know i didn't get from my own family i
remember our first christmas in that
apartment
um
we didn't have anything
and uh there was a charity
and they ended up giving us like a tree
and like some household stuff
but it was it was my pimp
that brought over uh
all the kids the the kids toys like
bunch of toys for my kids
and brought over stuff for them it's
probably my damn money but you know what
i mean he he acted like he cared
and um
that was hard for me to
to see
who he really was and how he was with me
because i was so stuck on that that
somebody was
finally acting like they cared about me
because when i had been with my
first husband
[Music]
his family disliked me
they never welcomed me into the family i
somehow always the bad guy
for something
so he never stood up for me
and i was like a you know outcast in
their family so this was the first time
that someone's treating me like family
and i thought i thought i loved him
because of that
and i can't say what kind of love it was
because it wasn't sexual
and it wasn't like a brother it was
i don't know i thought he loved me and i
thought i loved him
and um
then i was gonna
i was really lonely still like i wanted
somebody to
at that point i had gotten better at
hugging my kids
and touching them and and letting them
touch me and it was
almost natural
at that time
and so
and i had been letting go of my anger
i'd been talking to my
sisters and uh just seeing them once in
a while trying to like reestablish that
relationship because i really wanted my
sisters like i really wanted family
and um
i wanted i wanted something else i guess
i still wanted somebody else to
to love me like i wanted a man to love
me
so
i had a client um
met him at the casino
he was a millionaire he invented some
some chip for nasa something like that
and um i was gonna marry him
and we weren't in love
i was i think i was just happy somebody
wanted me
ah he was old i was like 20.
23 24
and this guy was like 65 at the time i
would date somebody 65 now
definitely
but not when i was in my early 20s for
sure not
wouldn't have anything in common
so i called my old pimp
and i told him what was happening
you know he wanted to know where i
disappeared to and everything and i was
like i got married didn't work out
and i guess i'm back on the street and
he was like
well
i'm atlanta i'm in atlanta why don't you
come down here
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
so my plan is like i'm just gonna make a
shitload of money i'm gonna i ended up
taking my kids to mexico
because my mom had moved down to mexico
at that time
and i asked her like can you please
please watch my kids for me because i
have nowhere to go
you know i have no money
and my mom she lives in
she lives in
a developing part of mexico developing
means third world country
so that's not anywhere for us to go
either
like people are trying to get out of
there and come here
so i'm just like can you just watch
these kids
and and she agrees to watch them for the
summer
and i'm like
i'm just gonna be like a super hoe for
the summer
and hoe as much as i can and make all
this money and then by the time the
summer is over i should have enough
money for an apartment
and and stuff for the apartment you know
and clothes and stuff for my kids
you know and they're gonna be starting
school they need school supplies i'm
thinking about all that stuff so i go
and i take my kids to mexico
and uh
i meet my pimp
in atlanta
atlanta georgia and uh
right away our relationship is is
different like i guess he's pissed that
i disappeared
and uh before when i was working with
him in detroit
at the end of the night
i would just give him half of my money
like he didn't take it from me
he let me pull it out and give him half
and and i got to keep the other half so
i could take care of you know whatever i
had to take care of
and then when i met him down in atlanta
he wanted all the money right away at
the end of the night
and he was setting me up on back page
and i hadn't uh really heard about
backpage then
but he showed me backpage and he's
making ads for me and having me do these
poses and it was trashy it was trashy as
[ __ ] the kind of clothes he wanted me to
put on
the shoes the everything and he wanted
me to charge like uh a hundred dollars
uh per client and it was
just one of the one of the um
he put me in this baymont and it had
roaches
and
i'm like i i'm never going to make any
money like this like what the f
and so it's like maybe
two or three weeks of handing my money
over to him and he's working me to death
like he's answering the phone he's
calling like all my clients talk to him
he sends my clients into the room
and i'm at the point
where my [ __ ] is so sore
from from being overworked
like it's all red and swollen i am to go
into the er because i'm like there's
something wrong here
and
um
nothing was wrong i was just really
really really sore from having way too
much sex and i guess
not nearly enough lube
and so
you know my pimp is mad that um i took a
day off to go the er and he's mad in the
evening he's coming to the hotel room
and like you know what's going on with
you
and um
at the time i had my own car
um
and so that's how i'd gotten to the er
and then got back to my room
and he's he's not having it he's telling
me he's telling me i have to work
he's got a funnel he's putting this
funnel in my [ __ ] and pouring lube down
it he's like you're gonna work
and
at this time
um when i met him
in atlanta i was also uh three weeks
post abortion
because i had been
pregnant with my second husband and i i
got an abortion the the week i left him
and i was telling my pimp you know he
kept rushing me to get to atlanta and i
kept telling him i can't like i just had
an abortion like i have to you know
you're supposed to wait like six weeks
or something before you even have sex
and here i am three weeks in but at the
same time i'm like i gotta get my [ __ ]
together for my kids
like we gotta i you know they need stuff
we need an apartment we need somewhere
to live they need school clothes
school's starting and we're going to ann
arbor and it's expensive to live in ann
arbor but that's where we're going
and uh
after that
he's like he takes my car keys he's
always waiting outside the room like
he's making sure that i'm taking clients
and i'm not going anywhere
i'm like this shit's different
and then he has another girl working i
don't know across town and another place
and he's got some trouble with her
i end up
getting my keys from him and leaving
when he goes and checks on this other
girl
and so i leave and
but i don't uh where am i going to go
i i'm still like we don't have anywhere
to live i can't go to mexico and pick up
my kids because i'm going to pick them
up with no money
and so i end up going uh went to
chattanooga tennessee and i made really
good money there
and uh more money than i made with him
and i took new pictures of myself and
posted my own ads and
um
i was like this [ __ ] doesn't even know
what he's doing with me like what an
idiot
and um
but i still want my money and
i honestly still love him like he's
there i guess trying to help me no one
else is helping me i asked other people
for help you know my sister and she
doesn't want to help so
um
i end up coming back from chattanooga
and i go back and see him in atlanta he
wants to know i guess i was throwing a
temper tantrum that's what i was doing
he wanted to know where i was at and i
was like look i went to chattanooga and
look at all this money i made
i made a [ __ ] ton of money and after
that you know his eyes really
and um
just a couple days after that i'm like
yeah this isn't going to work out
this is going to work out he put me back
in a shitty room and
and seeing all these clients and like he
didn't know how to take care of me
he didn't know what he was doing anymore
he was traveling around with this other
pimp and i think he was taking notes
from him or something like that
and
it just wasn't going to work out
i didn't as long as he was treating me
nice i guess i would have stayed
but he started to treat me shitty and i
was never gonna
i'm never gonna stand for it
not after my father
and so um
i end up
uh
telling him i want my money
and uh
at this point he traveled back up to
michigan and he's like
oh okay
i got your money fine you can have it
like i'm just stupid i guess at the time
and i meet him at this
red roof
to go get my money from him because i'm
like you know i still need that
and it's i think it's like
july 24th at this time so i got like a
little over a month before i need to
have my [ __ ] together get my kids and
when i show up to the motel
uh he had some people waiting for me and
i end up getting jumped
and uh my whole face is messed up at
this point
and at that time like as a prostitute i
had learned
do not get your face [ __ ] up
like anything else can get [ __ ] up so
at that time with all my clients i had
learned a lot of de-escalation skills
is what i call them
you know i can tell you learn how to
read people you learn how to read when
somebody is agitated or you know in a
certain kind of mood and you try to do
what you can to
you know to calm them down and make sure
things
go nicely so everybody has a good time
and uh
yeah so we [ __ ] my face up facial
fractures like i remember like
doctors telling me you know you can't
sneeze don't don't suck don't you grab a
shot just so many things you can't move
with your face or do so i'm like
definitely not sucking a dick for one
so um
not working my face is messed up can't
use my mouth and so i lay low in ann
arbor at an old college friend's house
for like maybe two and a half weeks
until my face is better
and then
i get my ass back down to atlanta
because there was good money down there
and
my pimp had already showed me what to do
like how to get the money and i already
figured out how to do it better than him
so i'm like let me go make some money
real quick i'm gonna go get my kids and
we'll go back to ann arbor and i'll
figure it out from there
and uh
so i went picked up my kids went back to
ann arbor i got you know got us together
and um
things are hard
at this point like i have bad credit and
nobody's willing to give me anything
like even a bank account or a cell phone
i can't get anything
and
i'm working third shift again
but i'm going down to atlanta once a
month because um
i end up
getting some really good clients down
there like some regulars
and then i
end up meeting up with some even older
friends from like a past past life that
i had
and i start
moving uh
i start picking up packages for them and
taking them down to atlanta every time i
go once a month for
seven years
so every time i make a trip down to
atlanta i make some good money from for
taking this package down there
and then i also make really good money
from my clients
and then i come home
and i start treating
the prostitution in ann arbor kind of
like a nine to five
like my kids go to school
and
i i go prostitute until it's time to
pick them up and i set my hours like on
my ad i'm like
you know
no appointments after 5 pm unless you
unless you call me and let me know
before 5 pm
because i'm gonna be at home my kids
making dinner like you think
you know i got a life man and so
and then it really turns out to be more
like a nine to three job because i like
to pick my kids up from school so
you don't see me before three i'm sorry
so i get it like that where all my
clients are like you know during the day
i'm like this daytime hoe and i'm like
it's working out and then i go to
atlanta down there once a month
and i'm trying to figure some [ __ ] out
like but at the same time
i feel
you know i feel trapped
i feel so goddamn trapped because uh how
am i gonna get out of this
what am i gonna what am i gonna do i
have no plan i have no way out
and i have no help
i have no family there's no one to call
you know after i learned about my mom
and my dad and their family it's like i
can't ask their family for anything
because it's going back into the lion's
den i don't want to deal with any of
those people
you know my my grandfather he touched me
he touched my mom molested her but he
touched me when i was a kid too
he ended up raping uh
his sister at a family reunion
when he was 45 he raped his youngest
sister who was 20 at the time he had 23
siblings
and she killed herself
two weeks later
after he raped her
my grandfather just got out of prison a
year ago
my mother's father he got out of prison
for a year ago after serving a couple
years for molesting a
nine-year-old year old little girl that
was associated with the family
and this is not just my mom's father
though it's like my whole family
aunts uncles they're you know there's
always something and i'm like i don't
want anything to do with it i'm trying
to do better i just want to do better
just please let me do better but i'm
trapped
and i'm like what am i supposed to do i
have these kids
and all the time i'm trying to do better
for the for my kids i'm trying to let go
of like
all this emotional trauma that i'm
holding on to because i really want to
be for them like who i needed
but i don't
i never found an answer
i didn't for
a really long time and then uh
i try to give them everything like you
know
whatever i needed
i tried to talk to them all the time
but trauma is a
it's more than just being
what you see on the outside and it being
generational and the
the effects
that happen that you can see
it's uh
it's in your blood and it's in your
brain
uh it's it's a
epigenetics i was reading this book and
they're talking about
uh the children of holocaust survivors
and all the problems
that they had
uh
medical issues and heart issues and
their uh
levels of depression that they dealt
with and
um because trauma's passed down like
even if
even if your kids didn't really go
through it or they didn't go through
something that was
as bad as you did
it still
really you know affects people it's an
as a sickness that we have to stop and i
i tried so hard to stop it you know with
with my own children
with my family
um
so when my kids uh
i don't know by the time my son was in
by the time my son was 12
like i hadn't spanked him anymore again
or anything like that i was like you
know what
hitting's not good i'm not gonna you
know it's no
i'm not doing that it's wrong i'm gonna
find other you know other ways to to
talk to my kids and be there and figure
out what's going on you know when they
do have problems
you know give them guidance instead of
what i thought was discipline
and i tried to instill the things
in them
that i had to build up within myself
like you know the self-discipline
self-confidence the self-reliance
self-control
i knew that my kids needed those things
as well
but the life i had given them with the
moving around
and spanking my son when he was younger
i can say right now that
neither of my kids are okay
i would like to think that they're okay
because i feel like
i'm finally almost okay
but my kids are not
they're strange from me
my son's birthday is today he's 20.
i kicked him
out when he was 18 years old
and this was hard for me because he was
my
you know i just had my son and my
daughter like that's it
so for me to have to tell my son you
have to leave this house it was hard but
my son uh he was getting older his voice
was getting deeper
during the pandemic it was just me and
him
we had disagreements and he started to
yell at me
and raise his voice
and when he started to yell at me
um
i couldn't i couldn't handle it
there's there's a lot that i have worked
through and that i've let go of
but
being yelled at
especially with with a man's voice
i can't handle it
and i didn't know what i was going to do
to my own son
but i knew that when that happens
when i get yelled at
it's like i'm a different person
and so it was maybe a couple days of it
and then i told my son i was like
i'm gonna have to you you you can go
live with your father who he had no
relationship with or i was like you can
live with your with your grandma which
was his uh
his dad's mom
and he chose to go live with his dad's
mom
and uh
i i chose to do that because i felt like
i knew he was gonna be angry with me for
making him leave but i felt like it was
gonna
after some so long he might get over it
he might work through it but had he
stayed
and continued to yell at me the damage
probably would have been irreparable
and
i didn't want that to happen so i didn't
abandon him
like i kept uh you know i i put my my
debit card on his phone so his apple pay
was my debit card you know i still
picked him up and took him to work
every day and then and then took him
back to his grandma's house you know
after work i was there i didn't abandon
him but he feels like i did
and i maybe in a way
i did
because i i did have to save
myself at that point
i
i guess that's something i haven't
worked through i can't be yelled at
and then my daughter um
we're estranged as well
because
my trauma
even though she didn't experience it
or anything like it
it still touched her
i made a point
not to lay my hands on her at all
when she was younger
my son he was mad he was like why
doesn't she ever get spanked or get in
trouble
and i was like are you being serious
right now
and so i grab my daughter and i start
spanking her
uh my son starts crying and i'm crying
immediately and my daughter is obviously
crying we're all crying and i'm like
that's why i don't spank her
you see what happened to you happen to
me and happen to her like we're all
angry like i can't even i can't
like she's just a precious little girl
and i didn't i
i would look at her and think about
myself as a little girl and i'm like
i don't know i had this i had this view
of men like i thought my son was
stronger you know what i mean
being an escort uh really changed me
because i could say you know there's
there's home money and then there's
escort money when people pay me to be an
escort they talk to me for hours and
hours and hours and
what i grew to learn about men
is that um they're just like us
as a woman i i thought they were strong
you know they're like
they're you know
they're tough you look up to them
they're you know
unbreakable
but then as escort sitting with them for
years and years over a decade of talking
to them hours i i learned that they're
just people they're just like us
and i guess i had to learn that about my
own son too so i shouldn't have spanked
him either because he was just a person
that didn't make it any better because
he was a boy and it didn't make it any
better that it was coming from a woman
so i guess escorting made me a better
mother
um
uh
but my daughter she uh
she's uh 15 now
and i haven't talked to her in two years
she lived with me until she was 13 and
then her dad started to like
really get his [ __ ]
together and uh
because he had went to prison for a time
after i left him for a distribution of
cocaine
and then he was in prison and then you
know trying to get on his feet and
become a better man now he's got you
know a house and a company
he's doing good and my daughter decided
to go live with him at the beginning of
the pandemic and uh she hasn't talked to
me in two years because
she says that she's
she got molested
when i dropped her off in mexico i
thought she was going to be safe with my
mom
but i don't know why i thought that
because my mom couldn't keep me safe and
she didn't keep herself safe but so
my mom's husband at the time ended up
molesting my daughter
and my daughter is angry at me for that
the same way i was angry at my own
mother
and so i get it
i understand why both of my kids
are angry at me and i understand
why they're not okay
and i tried to stop the cycle
of abuse
and
i hope
that someday
you know my son is going to forgive me
and my daughter is going to forgive me
and they're going to remember
all the things that i tried to teach
them
you know and pass down to them
so that
you know they can really stop the cycle
and so it just takes
time and you actually putting in the
work
and doing the work
you know i had to teach myself how to
forgive
how to forgive my mother
my sisters you know my father
i had to learn how to do those things
you know for my mother i had to learn
how to forgive her because despite
everything that happened i still loved
her and i wanted to love her freely
without any resentment or residual anger
there
and so
i think it's important to be kind to
people
and to forgive because if you
can do that for other people
it makes it easier to do that for
yourself
and then once you're able to do that for
yourself
then you can give it to the world
and i think that's what we need most and
what's more most important
all right dream thank you so much for
the
the long story that was interesting as
can be
you